good afternoon we we wanted to provide
an update on our immunization campaign
and so we want to make sure that
our community is aware of
what's happening with the campaign and
what are
our next step and what we're doing right
now
uh until today we have a minister in the
county
uh more than 29 000 vaccine doses
it does include vaccinating
all the the hospital
employees that that ask for the
vaccination
and and right now our local hospitals
are engaged in offering the the second
dose of vaccine to their to their
employees
and also we started vaccinated at the
rest of the
healthcare provider's workforce here in
in car county
as you may know the the vaccine is being
distributed in phases
we we right now are still engaged
in the first tier of offering vaccine to
her care
providers as you heard from
from the state and the governor this
week
the state of nevada modified its
fascination a playbook
and and now
it will be look at two different
priority lanes a one base on on
age and the other based on occupation
or or essential a workforce regroups
so right now the healthy street is
offering vaccines at
our main site at the catholic boulevard
and also
at a western high school also
our partners a society university
unlv roseman university
and toro university and collaborating
with us
in this fascination campaign and they
are also
offering this vaccine a different day
during the week
also this week the county will open
the customer center as our first mega
site
for the vaccination campaign and the
details of that
will be shared uh later on uh
i i also want to say that
starting tomorrow we will we will be
offering
vaccine to seniors a 70 years old
and over and and also
will start offering a vaccine to
today for the frontline community
essential workers and and that according
to the
to the state playbook is uh
is is the first block coming at the
public safety
which is already included into
the the target for this phrase of the
campaign
so in that a frontline community support
there are different groups
i will mention some of them for example
education which is
pretty much our country school district
employees and also employees from
a other health system here
in the in the county also
the nevada assistant higher education
which is the colleges and
universities included there
and uh and also included there are
a continuity of covenants which is a
city and county government
employees and staff as well as a
transportation
and and also a mortuary is services
and then there is a another group which
is a
more widely defined which is called
a community support a frontline staff
and and that's a relatively large group
and we will publish the definitions that
group so everybody can see that
properly yeah
we we we want to emphasize that uh
and now that we are expanding
our offer of vaccine today to the
community
we we need to be aware that uh
that this offering is is is contingent
to
to the availability of vaccines that we
receive from a
from the federal government and through
the state
our our capacity is starting
next week it will be
to to be able to vaccinate between 40 to
45 000 people a week
and our ability to reach that
number weekly uh of course
is depending on the number of vaccines
that we receive
every week and this is something that we
are
of course working with the state and the
federal authorities
in order to make sure that we receive
those vaccines
so what i mean by this is that we will
need a lot of support from our community
in terms of understanding that not
everybody can be vaccinated at once
because our capacity doesn't allow it to
raise
all our our residents at once
the vaccine will be available to
all our residents as we move forward
on this campaign
i i will stop here and i will introduce
our uh
which our chairman mr scott black
and then our a commissioner kilpatrick
to to follow up on this
thank you dr lagann i first just want to
say how much i appreciate the
the dedicated effort from you and your
team at the health district
i've spoken to miss rupert on a number
of occasions and
even though the health district is
working in concert with the state
uh in terms of allocation in terms of
building
and customizing the plan that works best
for southern nevada
it's uh critically important that we
create a branch out
approach to all the community partners
you mentioned in inchi
unlv csn we have lots of partners that
we need to lean on to make this
campaign successful so i just want to
say thank you to you and your team and
your leadership
definitely commissioner kirkpatrick for
her and her team for
the leadership to just she's she's the
one on the front line keeping all the uh
all she's the glue that keeping this
organization together in terms of this
this effort from beginning till now
with the pandemics i just want to say
thank you and uh you know from a north
las vegas perspective we're here to help
and be a partner
as well as as everyone else in the
community so thank you
thank you and thank you dr lagann
and um really um
for the press there's a couple things
that you can do to help us
uh help the community it's super
important that
folks remember that
this is being done very methodical and
we have to roll this out much like we
did with
testing so that we can work through the
bugs
and but we have a great model
and we will be rolling out this vaccine
so first and foremost
we ask for your patience because it does
take patience
to get through this and remember that
you already have the tools at home today
which is hand washing social distancing
that you can do to help us until we can
get to you vaccinated
uh but we are uh one we have two tracks
that we have to do
one most importantly is we have to
take care of our seniors because we know
our senior population 60 to 80
is the highest capacity in the hospitals
so it's very important we have that
track
at the same time we also need to
preserve our workforce
remember we're over one year into this
for many of us we started back in
january
of last year um having these discussions
so uh if the press you know understand
that we just need a little bit of
patience there are
several different groups that we have to
get to
we are asking employers to start
asking your employees how many are even
anticipating getting it
because as dr lagann pointed out that
does help
us kind of plan a little bit better with
our projections joanne is only as good
with the numbers as she knows what's
coming
and she has to try and balance um the
vaccines today
that we're getting versus um the highest
need out there
so dr lagon really the health district
has done yeoman's work on this and
i think most of us thought we would be
done around summer time however
i feel like this is the last hurdle in
the county and chief steinbach is
amazing with his
team i feel like we're in a good spot
and
the press can just help us navigate
over the next couple of weeks and we can
get through these groups that we will
have a well-oiled machine for you and we
will be able to move these vaccines
through our community so thanks for
having us on here
thank you um chief
uh just here to support you today dr
lagann and answer any questions
that may arise that run down me on the
operations side
or with emergency management so thank
you sir
thank you okay um joan is our
a chief amazing nurse and is leading our
vaccination
a campaign operation so joanne
please well hello good afternoon
everyone
and very happy to be here and share our
information
about our vaccination campaign and i do
want to say i really appreciate
the county and the chief steinbeck and
his crew for assisting us in getting
this vaccine out
as quickly as possible the county
and all the municipalities city of
henderson north las vegas
and las vegas mesquite and boulder city
have all been really helpful
in uh customizing our plan
for their communities so we're really uh
happy to have them on board
and they're getting us some resources
that we can get vaccine
out even quicker and we're looking at
doubling our capacity
in the next week or two and uh
also trying to serve the needs of those
over 70 years of age
which we're really relieved that we can
have that ability to do so
okay thank you johan corey
okay let's open it up now for questions
so if you are joining us by your
computer use the raise hand feature
which is at the bottom of your
participants list
our first question today comes in the
chat box from dana gentry
are there any vaccination sites outdoors
or are you planning to have any
outdoors
do you want me to take that
a question for chief steinbach or
right chief steinbeck as far as
logistics
uh many of us can answer that i'll go
ahead and let joanne answer and then
i'll
all add on to that sure i mean
um right now we have big enough venues
indoors to do vaccine which is
preferable
this vaccine has to be kept cold and so
if we're outdoors that can be
that can be very inconsistent so we
would rather do it
indoors if we if there is such a time
that we would have to move outdoors we
would certainly do that
but you know really giving a vaccine or
a medical procedure out in the elements
is not the best
practice right um
i just want to say that there are
additional vaccines coming
into the campaign that will be submitted
to the fda
for emergency use authorization
uh it's one of them like
the one from youngstown and johnson
probably might be
the one that could be used on that kind
of
scenario but still we have to wait for
those vaccines to be
authorized by fda thank you
and then i'll just answer to dana that
we've looked at outdoor facilities
um they are there as options as a
capacity and
grows they are they are options but
still within the restrictions that
joanne
at spoka but i just want to convey that
there's many outdoor locations and
facilities that are being considered as
options
next question today is from michael
scott davidson
hi there everybody michael from the
review journal thank you for taking the
time to do this press conference today
um
i had a question about the workforce to
actually get vaccines into arms if we're
planning on doing 40
000 to 45 000 per day um who will
actually be the people that are
you know administering the shots what
kind of training
will they have um and how will we pay
them and approximately how many will we
need
to administer that many per day so just
to recap on that how many people will it
take to administer 40 to 45 000 shots
where are they coming from what is their
training and what will we pay them
for how will we pay them
yeah sure uh so typically um
nurses are usually our front line
staff that we use for vaccine we have
been doing vaccine here at the health
district for many years
and we do it we've had an outreach team
that
has uh trained enough so that we can
train others so we have a train the
trainer model
so we are getting
vaccinators from the universities
the nursing schools medical schools and
training their uh professors to um
to train and also monitor
uh those vaccinators emts and paramedics
are now able to
be vaccinators so we have been doing a
train the trainer model with all of the
municipalities
so that they can get enough vaccinators
up and running
so that's how we've been doing it um and
it takes a lot of people to do to do
these
these clinics and we are getting another
partner clark county school district
nurses and they had been working with us
in testing
so that's where we're going to draw from
getting 40 000 to 45 000
in a week and we could we could
certainly do it i'm
totally convinced that we can do this
safely
and effectively for our population
go back to our chat box for the next
question from michelle price
she asks can we repeat the numbers
please 29 000
doses administered thus far and do we
know which frontline essential workers
will be up first starting tomorrow along
with those 75 and older
okay yeah okay so 29 000 is what is
uh then um
recorded and we expect um
twice that amount next week in the next
week and a half i would say
and uh the keep in mind we've been doing
frontline workers since december 14th
when the hospital started their workers
and that
filtered down to they're in their second
dose right now
um and then we're moving down the line
with
nursing homes and with those residents
so we've been
vaccinating not even a month yet and
we really had to wait till those folks
got their vaccine first and now we're
moving into
our tears we have um partners
working with our uh when i'm looking at
public safety and security on the
uh new plan uh that that
group is uh is uh moving along really
well
and we and but we're still working on
that big medical group there's about 50
000 people in there
so once we get it offered to everyone
then we move into the next group that
front line community to
support at the same time will we be also
offering vaccine
to those 70 and older and that we will
um do concurrently in
in a parallel fashion and uh
we just started doing that today are i'm
sorry we're starting tomorrow and then
through the next week
um so uh as we increase our capacity
there will be more opportunities for
that group to get vaccine
our next question comes from mary hines
hi um so our seniors are looking for
actionable information and they're
hearing
that they can get vaccinated tomorrow so
how can they do that
how do they go about it
well they can access our website for
appointments and keep in mind
appointments are limited at this point
however
we are getting more appointments uh
available
as as uh as we get these clinics up and
running
um some of the municipalities have uh
um have some capability as well
and we're going to be that's why we have
the county working with us
to be able to get messages out to those
over 70
and working with um communities that
they live in and also
working with the cities and uh those
senior centers and hospitals that may
have access
to that population right um and also
i i want to add that if
the pharmacies is made and working
they will start offering vaccine
january 20 according to information we
receive from
from the state and and the details of
how that's going to be
will be posted and shared once it is
received from the state and those
companies but
but the the seniors will receive the
vaccine from laws and also from those
pharmacies as well
so so mary this is marilyn i'm concerned
i want to make sure that your story
specifically says please don't come to
the health district
please don't come to umc if you do not
have appointment
please wait because we will not be ready
for you
so it's important that they know that is
78
and older are the limited appointments
that the health district has today
that they will be starting tomorrow so
as we
ramp up and as we get through the
community
we have many different avenues to get
through them
we believe within the next two weeks the
allocation
to the pharmacies will be done we are
working with the state to ensure that
there will be
we'll know exactly where they're at but
all of this is super important that
everybody realize the importance of
having an appointment because once you
open that file you have to give
the vaccines because we do not want to
waste any so it's important that people
know
if you take the time to make an
appointment please show up
because we're relying on you to be there
and if we don't um there's a reason why
we're limiting them because we know how
many
um clients that we got to see in that
time frame to make sure that we do not
waste any vaccines and we are super
proud
that out of 29 000 that have been
administered
less than 10 uh have had
some type of flaw so that's a great
we're taking great care with it so if
you could please ensure that
our residents know that it is slow and
methodical
and we um we will turn up the machine
real soon and we'll get them lots of
information but
this week i need them to please try to
get your appointments
and know that more information will be
coming this is a very fluid situation
and it'll take us
it'll take us a week or so to be able to
ramp it up
much like our testing and then everybody
can come
and a quick follow-up when do we expect
a mass vaccination clinic
well we've already started some mass
vaccination
clinics as you would they're closed pods
so they're kind of by
like my invitation only so we'll
probably be using that model for quite
some time
and so certain groups will be um
asked to make appointments and then we
check when they come in
whether they really belong to that group
or not
does that answer your question okay
i'm just wondering when or um it does i
i guess a follow-up would be how are you
verifying their identities
well either id or some type of if their
employer badge or some type of uh
identification like that age is easy
thank you can i ask were you asking when
we would have
sites open that would have uh increased
volume is that the question
it was yeah okay i'm wondering if
there's one of those really large
sites yes um
and when we might see that yeah
absolutely so cashman field is our is
our first of what we call the megapod
and so that has a soft opening of
tomorrow
which is to work out some of the
logistical issues that might be there
again that is with those front medical
providers that
will still be pushing people over there
to
tomorrow for that to occur
starting on friday
it will be opened up with increased
volume
hoping to be able to do 2000 a day our
hope is
that that site in the coming weeks will
be able to do 4 000 a day
and then we plan on replicating that as
necessary through the
through the valley as long as supply
and the human resources to push it out
match it which i believe will we will
have
the human resources side of it the
supply side
i would have to leave to dr lagann or
joann
right right thank you chief and also
we want to add that we will open a
second
mega vaccination site at las vegas
convention center and that probably will
be
within the last two weeks
our next question today comes from
astrid mendes
hello everyone i wanted to know you've
been mentioning about the
mega pots and and basically how is it
going to be for seniors but we have to
remember that there are some seniors
that are not in a senior center and they
do have mobility issues
so what is the plan to actually get a
hold of them
not everybody will have a right now they
will be able to go to this
megapod places and still they will still
need the vaccine so
what is it being done on that part and
uh my second question since we have
a lot of people um here in nevada that
have not been able to
register as citizens or residents here
because of you know everything that's
going on with the dmb what i'm trying to
ask with this is will
out-of-state residents will be able to
also be part
of this vaccination plan even
if they're not they don't have an idea
to show that they left here
or you know or any other form of
identification
but as long as they're part of the 75
group
will they'll be allowed to get their
vaccine
okay i want to start by the last
question and
move forward i think that that last
question is a very tricky one
and uh i i will add to that also
you know we have we know that there is a
relatively large undocumented population
here in
grand county what i would say
and the commissioner patrick and
and consumer and black and you know help
me
with this later is that we
is a person doesn't have a you know
a driver license or nevada because uh
you mentioned
that that is truly getting through mtv
and those kind of things
still they have to show groups of
residents here
because because otherwise is
what might happen is that we have you
know people who come here to during the
weekend
for you know for entertainment
now getting the opportunity to also get
the vaccine
in las vegas so that's uh that's a very
fine line that we
we have to work i don't know commission
i do want to ask sensation
sure and adrian to your point you had a
lot of questions within a question
and i think that's right as we work
through all of this we've had those
discussions
there are um so one of the things that's
why
we're you know there's a lot of folks in
our valley between 70 and 103
you know that's a pretty wide range
that's why we're starting with
78 and above because that's one group
that we can get and then as we
go through them we're going to get to
the next group
but look we've worked super hard worked
with the stage we
equality across the board that is why
we're running different tracks that is
why we
have a hispanic outreach group that is
working through those conversations that
the health district sits on
and many of our local latino groups
we have had several calls on dr lagana
myself with the face based
leaders because we are going to have all
of those people are going to help us
and then we are also working don't
forget with the department of aging
and with our seniors and home health
care workers
so we are fortunate that we are a small
community in the grand scheme of things
and that we can collaborate so there are
over 80 of us
that are on a minimum of uh
five calls a week where we collaborate
with other partners
so our goal is to be able to not miss
anybody who wants the vaccine as we roll
through this
but but it's going to take time you know
and so we've done
a fairly great job uh so far
with the limited resources and imagine
you know we don't know what we're going
to get for the vaccine the following
week so it's really hard to plan with
something that you're not aware of
we're hoping that that changes we've
been working with health and human
services
so we will continue to um
move through as we get through those 78
and older then we'll reach down to
you know i don't know what the number is
maybe it's 74 to 78
depending what that demographic looks
like and we'll continue to move
forward as we also ensure that our
workforce is safe
so uh you can be rest assured we're
working with
uh 144 different languages within our
community
and that we have many different
subgroups
faith-based leaders that we're all
working together and talking to ensure
that nobody gets left behind if they
want the vaccine did that help dr lego
i'm sorry
long answer could could i add a couple
things with that
they were talking about the difficulties
with people getting to these megapods
and we've we have been talking about
that and so
uh we're that's why we're going to
reserve um
appointments for those who have mobility
problems
to for example at the health district
here where the distances
isn't so much or other uh more
easily accessible and then i also
we are still working on getting a uh
a clinic for those with disabilities or
with cognitive issues
where you would not want someone in a
noisy big pot so
those are some things we are considering
and as far as
an id or whatever they would need for
vaccination
keep in mind if they live here they can
get a vaccine here
okay so we just asked for id because
it's a medical procedure we have to know
that yeah that's you
that's your birth date but beyond that
we don't
really collect any other information
except
general demographics so just to keep
that in mind that
we're not asking for um birth
certificates we're not asking for that
type of
of id if you don't have a nevada id and
you live here
and you have something else that that
can identify you
that that works just fine right
i just want to emphasize that we we
don't look for
immigration data so we don't ask for
that kind of
status from anyone that that's not a
requirement
for a person to get the vaccine here the
only requirement is that they are
nevada president and that's what we try
to
figure out i just wanted to say
regarding the seniors
also that as i mentioned before
the pharmacists will be also offering
vaccine to the seniors so they will have
that
a bit that a possibility in the
neighborhood
based on on the agreement between the
state and some of those pharmacies
before we move on i've got two things to
note if you are
hoping to do an interview with dr
elligan in spanish we will save that
for the end of the interview today so at
this time
please lower your hand and we will
return to you and if anyone has any
follow-up questions to questions they've
already asked please
send those to the office of
communication we do have a lot of
brand new people we want to get through
right now so our next question
we're going to take from joe moller wait
hold on
where'd you go okay there you go i'm
here
oh yeah this is joe moeller from uh
channel 8 here in las vegas
um i am wondering the number of
locations that the vaccine will be
administered
is there do you have a number of
locations that is and heard you just
mentioned
uh pharmacies um what sort of
information should people know about
what particular pharmacies will be able
to get this out and if you could also
clarify
someone had asked a question about 40 to
45
000 vaccines a day i just want to
clarify that is the goal for a week
okay uh okay information about
pharmacies the only information i can
share with you today
is that as today uh the the state
is is working this agreement with uh
walgreens against mid pharmacies now the
location of the pharmacy that's
something that will be disclosed by the
state
once they are ready to do that the the
plan is to
to start that program january 20 but
that's that information will come from
the state and we will share with you and
the second question was
oh sorry i muted him let me find him
again
joe can you raise your hand again oh
wait i just found you
all right there we go i figured it out
yeah someone had asked a question
earlier about
um the the goal a day and
i think is it 40 to 45 000 a week right
it's a week right it's a week and and
there are multiple
sites i i can tell you for we have the
site here at the cartoons from the
head street also we have the
western height school and also
ufv a rosemary university
a total university a catchment that
would
start a on certain friday
and also no las vegas no las vegas
we have also a unc we have the city of
henderson
and we have also a in the near future
mesquite and boulder city add to that
equation
and and that's that's that's pretty much
what we have right now
joanna i think that's that's from our
table
i don't think i'm missing any right now
yeah i think that i think that would
cover it and and we may find um other
partners
in the future but those are the main
ones right now yeah
next up is jaclyn schultz from fox5
hi everyone uh looking for some
clarification on the
78 and up is that only for
uh the southern nevada health district
site
uh not for the pharmacies or the cashman
center
and then um a big question i have is
practically what do you need to know and
prepare for
when you go to an appointment how much
time um
definitely your id proof of residence
any other medical documents if you have
uh
allergies or whatnot and then uh where
does your personal
information go a lot of people have
questions about
privacy you know yeah
sure um so when they come to
any of the um mass vaccination clinics
an id um if they're in a group some type
of proof of that they're in this group
like a pay stub or something like that
um and uh possibly some insurance
information we're not collecting that
now but we may be
in the future and uh
and they should know about their medical
history
as far as anaphylaxis
if they've ever had a a
reaction to a medication or food that
would cause
them to use an epipen and those with the
conditions that may suppress the immune
system
and so if if they have a
that type of condition or they're
pregnant or breastfeeding they should
really discuss with their doctor
first and determine whether they should
get the vaccine or not
um those are the main main questions
also
um if they've had a vaccine in the uh
14 days before the date of
their coveted vaccine we cannot
vaccinate those
individuals so we screen for those right
away when they come in
and then they um you know
get the vaccine from the provider and
then we have them
stay for about 15 minutes um to
monitor to make sure that they're okay
and that there is no reaction and then
we have
us medical support if that does occur
i would say it's really hard to say how
long it would take
i mean it could take anywhere maybe 10
minutes maybe 20.
i mean it or if you have to wait in line
if people really adhere to the
appointment system it goes a lot quicker
so um did that answer all your questions
joanne i think she's asking and you know
i've been accused of misquoting and
everything so it is 70 and above
that yes uh what's in this but i thought
that i heard
um dr lagann say that we were going to
try and manage
our seniors so that we didn't have a
free-for-all so we were trying to
limit groups but it is 70 and above so
please do not
misquote two seniors because they're
already um
calling because they all want to know
but but we have to figure out how to
manage uh the seniors so that we don't
have
thousands of seniors showing up at the
same time
and sitting outside and waiting for
hours and and that's really what we're
trying to avoid
so it is 70 and above yes
yes but we're trying to manage groups so
that
we um ensure that we protect our seniors
while they're waiting to get protected
right that yes it's 70 and above and
i think you were asking about pharmacy
access too
uh how will that go and that is yet to
be determined
i i would um
guess that though that access will be
done through the pharmacies they're
pretty good at
getting their information out there we
our website will
continue to compile
information on clinics and access on our
website
uh as we as we find out that information
joanne i think jacqueline also asked
about the privacy
of the information that they supply when
they um make an appointment
correct so um our you know we
it is a medical record so um we have
uh security in place so that
uh people um do not have access to to
that record except for those who really
need to have it
okay so uh our
uh documentation system is secure
and as well as like for example
like the hospitals and and
unlv are using a system electronic
system
that um is what everyone
else uses in their medical offices
and in their hospital so it's the same
type of system
our our vaccine information is required
by state law to be reported to the state
immunization nevada webi z is the
immunization
information system and uh so that people
can look
and they can find their own record
through a patient portal
and they can get their record through
that so
that's exactly where the the data
resides
it resides in any medical uh office
like our system or if it's unlv it's
it's
um their epic system and same thing with
umc and all the hospitals
what we are doing at the um
for cashmen will be residing in in our
data
so it it is handled the same as if you
would come to our office and get any
other procedure
we're going to take one more voice
question today and two questions from
the chat box so our next
voice question comes from frank
if we can get them unmuted
there you go hi what's up frank nemec
the board of health for the southern
nevada health district
my question is does the health district
plan on continuing to hold back
half the doses in preparation for a
subsequent
boost in three to four weeks or will the
vaccines be administered as they arrive
so the vaccine is is not held the
second dose is not held here at the
death health district
it's held at the federal level so the
federal
government reserves that second dose
and um when it's needed it gets shipped
to us
so we don't have it on hand um
however um we're
it is our understanding through
communication with cdc
and the state is that when we are ready
to
when that is due then that vaccine will
be shipped to us and then we give
that concurrently with all the other
first doses
does that make it clear
well i i i i just want to add that
uh according to
you know news coming from regarding the
the next administration actually
there will not be any more holding of
the second dose
and that probably will happen after the
change of administration
next question from the chat box comes
from damon smith
asking how will vaccinations be tracked
once hospitality employees are included
and will employers have access in order
to track completion
at our properties
well typically um employers
it is a medical record and um so
typically employers are not do not have
access however we all know that
many medical facilities you know do keep
track of vaccinations of their
employees so typically what
employers would do is ask for that
documentation
that they have received the vaccine
excuse me
for uh for a particular reason so
at this point um
it will it's accessible to the
individual only
and their health care providers okay
let me clarify here because uh just just
to make sure everybody understands
okay the question was a i believe in
hospitality hospitality
people which is different from the
hospital
people the the hospital they have the
dual function of being
employers and also they're administering
the vaccine so
just because of that particular
situation
they they have a pretty good idea of
of how many employees are are being
vaccinated
that doesn't happen to the rest of the
community
because the the information
from the people who receive the vaccine
is
is is is actually protected by hebrews
with confidential information
and the health district cannot release
that information
to the employer so
it is certainly a function
between the employer and the employee
on how they want to to communicate
that kind of information among
themselves but the health district can
do
cannot assist any employer with that
kind of information
another question from the chat box uh
gerard ramalho from channel
3 is asking will all vaccines require
appointment
through the health district even if
they're at a pharmacy
no no it doesn't they have the street
what is doing is just facilitating the
information to the community so we
we are trying to post in our website
as much information as possible to help
our community
identify a vaccination site where they
can go
and get the charts uh is
is not a requirement that each pharmacy
uh place their registration
site in in our website we are just
providing a service to the community so
the answer to that question is no
okay two well i'm sorry marilyn go ahead
commissioner kirkpatrick you are muted
at this time please
unmute yourself sorry sometimes it's
good if i mute myself
so uh what i just want to press upon to
the press is
uh you know this is no different than
how we do the flu shots you know we have
several
pharmacy partners where you can go to
your local pharmacy
you can make the appointment with them
to get their flu shot or you can choose
to come to the health district
um this is just a bigger scale of doing
it
so it's not new except it's much
bigger this is what the health district
does do
this is how we work with our community
partners across
um the valley um even when it comes to
employers
employers may ask for to make sure that
you got your tv
shot right or to make sure that um
you got your healthcare chat so um the
employers
um that's entirely up to them but for us
as a health district
this really is just on a bigger scale
it's a little bit harder to navigate
much because of the
sensitivity of the vaccine so we have to
be mindful of that
but um this that is one of the reasons
why we've brought
so many partners in because people are
used to uncomfortable
going to the walgreens or to dismiss
to get their flu shot and we want them
to have that same option
or they can have one of the other sites
so it's important that
we not scare people from getting the
vaccine
although it's a little bit rough in the
beginning as it is
any other normal flu season we're trying
to get as many of them out so i just
want to make sure that people understand
that this
is what we normally do
every year uh pre-flu season
uh and this is just another vaccine
within our wheelhouse that we have to
move forward with and
we want people to um realize that we
have a
a lot of folks that get the flu shot
and it should be we're working very hard
to mirror that operation so that they
have
options that they're comfortable with
at this time we will be wrapping up the
english portion of this interview
if you are from the media and you have a
follow-up question or
or a new question please feel free to
reach out to the office of
communications
if you're a member of the public feel
free to send an email to snhd
public information at snhd.org
and we'll be happy to get back to you as
soon as we can and if you are looking
for all of our coveted information
including how to make an appointment
our direct covered website link is
www.snhd
dot info slash covid but please be
patient because we are experiencing high
volumes of traffic on the site today
so it may be slow at times